hat der hammerwurf passt perfekt
orientalisch gewöhnt ja geradezu mama da
wo sie doch richtig schön haus
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute eine
kräfte kartoffel rolle weil ich finde ja
immer so zum fastenbrechen oder wenn die
möglichkeit außerhalb vom ramadan oder
wenn ihr nicht was das auch zum
mittagessen kartoffeln in kombination
mit hackfleisch geht einfach immer oder
und heute habe ich mir gedacht wir
machen mit erstmal erst mal kümmern wir
uns natürlich um das kartoffel bett beta
kommt da eine hackfleisch masse drauf
und dann wird das ganze auf geräumten
dafür brauchen wir erstmal kartoffeln
ich nehme vorwiegend festkochende die
finde ich persönlich am besten geeignet
da wenig kochende können sich ein
bisschen schwierig zu mir das wort
gestalten genau dieser und das da fange
ich jetzt einfach an das ganze zu stehen
und gleich nehme ich mir meine reise und
dann reibe ich einfach fröhlich vor mich
hin und das gleiche manche bringt auch
mit käse
[Musik]
so ich hab jetzt kartoffeln und käse
gerieben und jetzt ist es wichtig dass
wir die kartoffeln einfach noch mal so
ein bisschen aus zu bringen dann merkt
ihm nämlich dass so ein bisschen saft
austritt und dann kommt das mitte zu zum
käse und dann würden wir nur noch mit
salz verfahre ich dem thymian dazu und
das hab ich noch muskatnuss passt auch
immer gut zu kartoffeln und zwei eier
für die bindung dürfen auch nicht fehlen
[Musik]
so die kartoffelmasse ist jetzt fertig
den ofen habe ich vorgeheizt auf 190
grad ober und unterhitze und ich habe
jetzt hier mein gelochte spart wenn ihr
das dann verwendet das sehr gerne da
habe ich jetzt backstop hier oben drüber
getan und dann kommt da einfach die
gesamte masse oben drauf und wird
gleichmäßig verteilt dass es deshalb so
wichtig da durch das wir halt
gleichmäßig verteilen wird es dann auch
gleichmäßig im ofen ich will jetzt in
wirklich so hangar dank gehören also
seid wichtig damit es halt auch
gleichmäßig backt
[Musik]
so das ist übrigens der zwischenstand
nach 20 minuten könnt ihr das ganze aus
dem ofen nehmen und erst mal kurz
beiseite stellen so für den hackfleisch
part brauchen wir jetzt einfach nur ein
bisschen öl in der pfanne und natürlich
hackfleisch ich habe jetzt durch zufall
tatar gekauft das ist hackfleisch mit
ganz wenig fettanteil bei dem rezept
funktioniert aber hat mit relativ hohem
fettanteil ganz gut ich nehme jetzt
einfach ein bisschen mehr öl dafür dass
könnt ihr immer ganz gut ausgleichen und
was ich auch schon gemacht habe ist ich
habe schon eine zwiebel fein gewürfelt
und meine rote paprika beim gemüse seid
ihr auch so teil variabel ihr könntet
jetzt auch zb wie bei der lasagne ganz
ganz fein gehackt möhren dazugeben es
funktionieren auch erbsen ganz gut oder
mais und jetzt habe ich eine
knoblauchzehe sie kommt hier schon
direkt in mein öl und da dünnste ich
dann auch die zielen mit einem paprika
gebe ich auch mit dazu und nachdem das
dann so ein bis zwei minuten dünsten
durfte kommt dann das hackfleisch dazu
und wird dann auf höherer stufe schön
krümelig gebraten
[Musik]
so das hackfleisch ist jetzt ja und da
geben wir jetzt die gewürze mit dazu ich
habe gerade auch noch paprika mark dazu
gegeben falls sie kein paprika mark habt
dann geht auch tomaten macht aber ich
finde den paprika immer geschmeckt in
dem fall einfach ein bisschen besser
sondern kommt da natürlich salzstadt
zurück ich gebe noch paprikapulver
edelsüß und paprika flocken also cool
wie werde mit rein und im prinzip
braucht ihr da eigentlich keine weiteren
gewürze was ich gerne mag noch einfach
petersilie einfach petersilie dazugeben
und dann mit ein bisschen sahne
verfeinern ihr könntet auch passierte
tomaten nehmen einfach damit die masse
jetzt nicht zu kümmerlich trocken ist
sondern dass da einfach noch mal so ein
bisschen das ist einfach so ein bisschen
deftiger seien für die rolle
[Musik]
die sahne habe ich wirklich noch so zwei
minuten ein bisschen einkochen lassen
dass es einfach schön sämig wird und
jetzt kommt diese masse einmal auf die
käse kartoffel platte und dann wird das
einfach nur aufgerollt
[Musik]
das aufrollen geht echt easy weil das
backpapier erledigt die ganze arbeit
also braucht euch da gar keine sorgen
machen einfach immer wieder so ein
bisschen was abnehmen und gleich werde
ich sie auch noch in portionen ein teil
aber typisch türkisch ist jetzt
natürlich noch knoblauch joghurt benehmt
euch ich habe jetzt die 35 prozentige
können doch komplett fettarm oder sanyo
dass die zehnprozentige könnt ihr auch
nehmen da kommt jetzt einfach knoblauch
dazu mit meiner knoblauchpresse müsst
ihr übrigens dass ich sagen es ist total
gewundert ihr müsst ihr nicht schälen
der fängt die schale automatisch auf als
sie landet nicht bei euch im joghurt so
braucht dazu selbst darf nicht fehlen so
ein bisschen und ich mache jetzt
zusätzlich noch und dafür die pari
wird's mit reinem das handel kräuter
gewürze ihr könnt sie weglassen aber
wenn ihr sie da hat macht sie gerne rein
schmeckt richtig gut und danach kommt
natürlich noch eine paprika soße dies
auch typisch türkisch ich weiß dass man
einfach an daniel
wild wald sei genau salzmann weil dann
ist nämlich der joghurt part schon
fertig kommt an die seite und für die
paprika soße nehmen wir uns jetzt
einfach hier somit kleine fahne da kommt
paprika mark rein zusammen mit ein
bisschen öl
ich nehme einfach neutrales öl und dann
auch gewürze wie paprikapulver edelsüß
natürlich ein bisschen salz zucker passt
auch perfekt aber auch nicht zu viel und
damit das ganze einfach mit wasser
angerührt und das war es auch schon
[Musik]
also wenn es komplett authentisch
türkisch möchtet dann auf jeden fall
noch münster dazu geben und dann gesagt
einfach nur noch so ein bisschen
einkochen lassen
[Musik]
das ist noch ein vor gedrehtes video das
heißt es ist noch nicht ganz ramadan
aber wer aber wir waren mit solchen test
für euch bitte schön danke schön sie ist
nintendos wii ist aber die falsche haus
ist ja
das kriegst du hier also ich finde dazu
könnte man jetzt noch
gebraucht nicht mein messer und ich
würde jetzt wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
beschreibt ich würde zu servieren die
suppe vielleicht so eine linsensuppe
oder mitmachen suppe salat daneben das
dazu perfekt dann habt ihr eure mini
habs jetzt auch übrigens aufgewärmt weil
wir jetzt gar fotos gemacht haben das
heißt ich kann dank botox aufgewärmt
auch noch gut schmeckt
[Musik]
das sind kartoffeln und käse also außen
sind es kartoffeln und käse mit
natürlich gewissen von innen drin ist
eine lecker gewisse hackfleisch oder
dass wir die jetzt nicht aufgenommen das
muss ich gar nicht was ich doch zeitung
hat halten aber das ist mit dem mega lag
hat der hammerwurf passt perfekt die
paprika soße ist perfekt generell so
heißen kartoffel ist ist immer irgendwie
geil das schmeckt immer negativer aspekt
habe ja aber so klein das stimmt der
stimme ich zu sein wie es aus aber das
muss er nämlich den größeren kopfhörer
orientalisch gewöhnt ja geradezu mama
und sie doch richtig schön haus ich bin
aus dem tippschein und bekommt und so
das ist richtig schön aus wirklichkeit
ist nicht gemerkt habe unser hintergrund
hat sich ein bisschen geändert das haben
wir da in der zwischenzeit noch da habe
ich nochmal erwerben für den test
technik immer noch mega lecker das heißt
ihr könnt es sehr schön vorbereitet
kurzweil joghurt draufmachen servieren
paprika soße obendrüber perfekt ich bin
begeistert ich wünsche euch viel spaß
und nachmachen und haben
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten
rezept
[Musik]